E aí
e a sociedade
já percebeu que é importante
incentivaram da mesma forma meninos e
meninas quando o assunto é investigar o
mundo ou cuidar da casa todo mundo sabe
disso
é mas experimento a fazer uma busca no
Google sobre
brinquedos de meninas
e agora vamos fazer uma busca sobre
brinquedos de meninos
E essas são minhas irmãs e eu em algum
dia comum em nossa casa em Curitiba no
final dos anos 70 e já que somos nós que
os nossos pais que sempre nos
estimularam a sermos o que quisesse
morcego e nos tornamos
fisioterapeuta engenheira química
publicitária
eles nos dízimos diziam que precisávamos
empreender desde cedo tínhamos que ser
Donas do nosso futuro que sorte a nossa
é mas dizem que é mais fácil olhar a
história se a gente olha pelo retrovisor
mesmo estimular dentro de casa minha
geração não olhava muito para o lado
procurando referências femininas
talvez porque elas não estivessem ali
para nos estimular profissionalmente ou
talvez porque as minhas referências eram
homens e por muitos anos as minhas
atitudes tiveram que ser parecidas com
as deles no mercado de trabalho
demonstrar emoção
fraqueza misturar minha vida pessoal com
a profissional
amadorismo não ter tempo para me dedicar
100% para o meu trabalho era um absurdo
mulheres são maioria no Brasil tem maior
grau de instrução formal
quarenta por cento das famílias são
chefiadas por mulheres
é quase a metade das pequenas empresas
são abertas por mulheres Mas quando
olhamos o mercado de trabalho esses
números são diferentes tanto no mercado
público quanto no privado
menos de três por cento dos seus das
grandes empresas do Brasil são mulheres
e a pandemia do coronavírus afetou
principalmente elas e ainda diminuiu uma
tendência de alta que tinhamos no
mercado de trabalho
e se olharmos as mulheres com filhos a
maternidade parece ter sendo uma
penalidade na carreira da mulher apenas
seis em cada dez mulheres voltam ao
mercado de trabalho após serem Mães
e talvez por isso 55 porcento das
empreendedoras mulheres e 75 por cento
dessas resolveram empreender após serem
mães talvez sendo donas os próprios
negócios elas possam conciliar o tempo
entre cuidar das atividades escolares
levaram ao médico cuidar das compras
pessoais da família
as mulheres gastam em média 9 horas
semanais a mais do que o homem nos
cuidados da casa
e são elas que
abre mão dos Happy Hour depois da escola
depois do trabalho são elas que abrem
mão talvez do futebol depois do horário
de expediente
no final de um ano são três meses de
trabalho em tempo integral que as
mulheres Gastão nos cuidados com a
família
Agora vamos fazer um outro recorte o
mercado da tecnologia
a vinte por cento das cadeiras de das
Universidades em áreas de ciência da
computação
são ocupados por mulheres
em apenas trinta por cento são
pesquisadoras na área de ciências e
matemática
a vinte por cento dos profissionais das
áreas técnicas empresa de tecnologia são
mulheres e dezessete por cento dos
programadores no mundo inteiro são
mulheres
dezessete por cento e elas ganham em
média trinta por cento a menos do que
eles no mercado de trabalho
e além das cadeiras das universidades
nas áreas de tem a questão das mulheres
no mercado de trabalho parece ser
desincentiva Du desde a infância
uma pesquisa da Microsoft revelou que as
mulheres vão se desinteressando pela
área de exatas à medida que crescem aos
11 anos elas têm o mesmo interesse sobre
Ciência e matemática mas aos 15 Elas
começam a se desinteressar
os motivos conforme a pesquisa são a
falta de modelos femininos na área a
falta de confiança na Equidade de gênero
entre meninos e meninas para área de
exatas EA falta de contato com
programação e cálculo antes da faculdade
e parece que a sociedade estimula o
estereótipo que meninos são melhores por
exatas e meninas são melhores para
humanas e por que que esse recorte da
mulher na tecnologia é importante o
mercado da tecnologia é o que deve gerar
mais empregos nos próximos anos quando
os avanços da Inteligência Artificial da
robótica vão fazer uma mudança muito
grande no mercado de trabalho
estima-se que mais de 350 mil vagas de
emprego serão abertas até 2024 e o
mercado prevê falta de profissional para
ocupá-las
e a inteligência artificial é uma
tendência na maioria dos segmentos onde
o aprendizado os insights das máquinas
são fundamentais para decisão
dos negócios em todos os segmentos
mas se o aprendizado de máquina inicia
com uma intervenção humana como teremos
Equidade de gênero sem apresenta das
Mulheres nesse segmento
e a internet das coisas conecta objetos
comuns
óculos de realidade virtual roupas com
sensores conectados transmitindo
centenas de dados os mais diversos via
internet
e as questões de casas e até órgãos
construídos a partir de uma impressora
3D
médicos virtuais de Diagnósticos
baseados em inteligência artificiais são
cada vez mais comuns no centro os
médicos e se falarmos sobre assistentes
virtuais que organizam a nossa rotina o
nosso dia a dia os insights e ao
aprendizado desses assistentes virtuais
são superutes na nossa rotina a corrida
da Computação quântica é uma realidade e
os supercomputadores estão aí
bom e o que as mulheres perdem dessa
corrida a gente pode falar sobre
empregabilidade
aquela centenas de milhares de empregos
que serão gerados não serão ocupados por
mulheres pois elas não estão se
qualificando nas universidades para isso
com o medo que as máquinas ocupem o
lugar dos humanos na verdade a maioria
dos empregos que ocupam mulheres um
salários de média de média salarial
baixa como atendimento ao cliente
mercado
administrativo estão os que mais correm
risco de sofrer automação
é mas existe uma sequela ainda maior se
a gente falar sobre a falta de presença
da mulher na tecnologia do que apenas a
falta de empregabilidade
e num dos exemplos super famosos sobre a
questão da
discriminação algorítmica um foi se
percebido que o sistema de recrutamento
via Inteligência Artificial da Amazon
suprimir currículos femininos no
processo seletivo Eles foram ensinados
que as mulheres não eram boas para área
no outro exemplo numa outra pesquisa se
percebeu que as mulheres são menos
impactados por anúncios do Google por
vagas de emprego de salários de
remuneração alta
mais um exemplo uma imagem um homem numa
cozinha comum na frente do fogão
cozinhando oitenta por cento das vezes o
algoritmo colocou a tag mulher ao invés
de homem para classificá-lo
e esse falarmos das assistentes virtuais
que também são programadas baseadas
nessa nossa sociedade sexista
e
o comportamento tanto dos humanos com
relação a máquina Quanto dá as respostas
da máquina com relação humano
mostraram um comportamento serviu e
suscetível abusos os assistentes
virtuais eles repetem padrões de
submissão
eu nunca na verdade a própria voz
feminina de quatro totalidade dessas
assistentes virtuais
Alexa Siri Bia magalu são reforçam esse
estereótipo da mulher como cuidadora
assistente objetificada
e não criar um viés algoritmo
algorítmico é muito difícil
porque na verdade ele
repercute e repete os preconceitos
estruturais da sociedade
a Essa sociedade que segue sexista
racista classista
e as empresas que estão programando as
máquinas que estão mudando
comportamentos
produtos e serviços estão discutindo
essa Equidade em seus meios os mais de
oitenta por cento de homens
programadores se dão conta desses vieses
para corrigir esses erros ou melhor para
produzir inteligência artificial imagem
computacional diferente do que temos
visto hoje
a mudar essa lógica não é uma tarefa
fácil
a mudar a lógica é das novas gerações
Principalmente
olhando para elas Eu Vejo um caminho
promissor nós vemos casais jovens se
preocupando em dividir melhor a o tempo
entre tarefas domésticas e o trabalho os
meus dois filhos tanto ele quanto ela
discutem abertamente esse tema na mesa
de jantar mas nós precisamos mudar o
mercado de trabalho o mercado
corporativo
enquanto vermos produtos e serviços
discutir vos mudando o comportamento de
a sociedade
continuamos com os mesmos padrões
conservadores na sociedade nas
universidades no mercado de trabalho se
continuarmos como estamos
levaremos séculos para conquistar
Equidade temos que ser disruptivos temos
que ser discutir vos em nossas casas
disco É verdade a divisão entre homens e
mulheres nas atividades domésticas temos
que ser desculpe ativos na criação dos
nossos filhos permitindo de verdade que
as meninas sejam tão inventiva
investigativas quantos meninos
nós temos que ser discutidos nas escolas
não permitindo que as meninas se
desinterés em pela área de exatas
e nas universidades criando Ambientes
diferentes acolhedores para a presença
das mulheres em cadeira System
nós temos que ser competitivos no
mercado de trabalho discutindo a
licença-maternidade
discutindo a jornada de trabalho
discutindo ascensão de carreira sobre
Claro ponto de vista de qualificação de
competência Mais também tomando em conta
a diferença natural de comportamentos
que fazem com que as mulheres têm
prioridade para uma coisa e os homens
para outra
os homens e mulheres serão afetados pela
Inteligência Artificial
pela robótica
pela internet das coisas pelo avanço dos
5g
+ os caso da Equidade está na falta dos
seus das empresas porém sessenta por
cento das empresas não possuem políticas
Claras para ascensão de carreira se eles
estão com a caneta de contratações e de
atenção eles precisam enxergar para
mudar e é Assis vieses inconscientes
essa falta de a presença de estereótipos
esses ambientes tóxicos das empresas de
tecnologia se une para causar Talvez uma
tempestade perfeita contra a Equidade de
gênero
adversidade e eu tô falando de gênero
aqui mas toda diversidade poderá
equilibrar esse mundo cada vez mais
tecnológico poderá equilibrar a questão
da vida pessoal EA vida profissional que
não estados associada e quando eu
resolvi corri uma correu uma maratona o
meu aprendizado com a superação com as
regras me fizeram ser uma lida é melhor
para o meu time assim como criar meus
filhos na adolescência na infância e
acompanhá-los pela adolescência
as festas com os meus amigos são tão
importantes quanto os capiaus com os
meus colegas de trabalho
tudo que fizemos nos fazem chegar aqui
somos a soma do que vivemos
em toda nossa história nos faz alcançar
o sucesso
Ah e ainda valeria a gente discutir o
que é sucesso
mas isso vai ficar para o próximo
assunto para uma próxima conversa
obrigado a